parks and rec is about to get medically
wrecked
i've been shocked
why is no one calling why do they think
they could solve this like this is an
office issue i was shot in the head with
a shotgun ron it's actually not that
serious i just need you to stay calm
okay yeah i'm just gonna stay angry i
find that relaxes me okay here's your
sky okay jerry jerry's here here's your
scotch run here we go ron okay scotch
can actually make you bleed more so
that's not something that we want the
pain medication i gave you is pretty
strong donnie uses it for menstrual
cramps how many did you take
seven eight
better wash them down with plenty of
fluids no ron you cannot drink scotch
with this you're gonna need to purge
right now pain medications especially
ones that include acetaminophen aka
tylenol with alcohol can be quite
disastrous in fact one of the leading
causes of acute liver injury happens to
be tylenol intoxication whether on
purpose or even by accident i see it
quite often when patients are like oh i
took some tylenol and then i took some
corsidin or nyquil these are all things
that contain acetaminophen but because
they have different brand names people
don't realize it and they like get a
toxic dose of tylenol we recommend
ideally maxing out a two thousand
milligrams of tylenol a day but the max
dose is four thousand this is thrown
around good i will bite you roll in your
mouth right now get yourself that if a
cat this would make it a lot easier hey
ann are you still a nurse or did they
fire you because you slept with all the
doctors whoa someone belongs on grey's
anatomy and he's not feeling well what's
wrong andy he's got a headache and i'm
seeing double and i got a song stuck in
my head and my teeth hurt also i'm
hungry not gonna lie most of my patient
visits go exactly like this for us
doctors we want to address one concern
at a time in order to give it adequate
time and effort but patients don't work
by check boxes so they tell you
everything that's wrong with them and
then we have to decide is this all due
to one cause or are we gonna take this
apart in several visits did you hit your
head yeah he was hanging up his gold
record
oh my god are you okay
yeah
i'm good
look to the left
all right
whatever
the best funoscopic exam i ever seen you
can't do a proper funoscopic exam when
the patient looks so far to the left and
so far to the right because you gotta
look through the pupil well if it's a
concussion it's extremely mild so i
wouldn't worry about it
anything else bothering you the way that
i like to do it is say okay based on
reason x y and z is why i don't think
this is inherently dangerous right now
things you need to be on the lookout for
are x y and z the patient can then
understand why i'm making the
recommendation to understand that if
something changes that now is outside of
my initial recommendation they know when
to come back got a weird uh rash in my
knee pit sometimes when i walk my ankles
make like a weird rattle snake sound
broke my thumb on the way over here whoa
that's a serious break there's a lot of
bruising we made like a hundred million
doctor's appointments for ourselves in
one week after this we won't have to go
to the doctor for like 10 years that's
not true but seeing a family medicine
doctor is really ideal because a lot of
these problems are really not requiring
the consultation with a sub-specialist
we can handle them in family medicine so
dr harris seems to be a lacking oh
let's get you home and get me some ice
cream
here's your bill
whoa yeah we'll be needing that i've got
the pre-medicine card
free medicine deductible for dental
procedures oh i think uh you're wrong we
have the insurance thing i believe we're
covered it's still five hundred dollars
you know what
dina dash
out of the way
wait he got a dentist appointment and
then he's in an icu all of a sudden
where is he
i'm making the water fountain hygiene
upgrade our number one priority oh great
for some reason when people in pawnee
use the water fountain they put their
mouths completely open oh
oh my god that's my worst fear oh it's a
surefire way to get herpes speaking of
it i have a hernia uh this morning i
made the mistake of sneezing
oh
that looks like he has an inguinal
hernia where intestinal contents
actually go through the inguinal canal
into your scrotum that's right you can
end up with intestines in your scrotum
but as long as i sit still and don't
move i'm good i got this the most
dangerous part about having a hernia is
if it becomes strangulated which means
that within the opening that was created
and that it went through some kind of
inflammation happens or stress happens
where it starts getting choked out and
this choking out actually cuts off the
blood supply to that part of the
intestine thereby causing its necrosis
and dye which leads it to develop an
infection so a strangulated hernia is a
surgical emergency
that's actually really funny but the
best part about being an mri technician
is
i can see inside everything
if you look inside the steak or this
butter or this bread well if you look
inside this bread all you're gonna find
is more bread i don't know i'd have to
do an mri
i mean i've never even had an mri before
what
is he taking her to get an mri in a
claustrophobic loud little space that
you have to sit for long periods of time
oh i don't know about this
well i'm offering you a free scan
usually costs up to two thousand dollars
free scans are not necessarily good
scans in our bodies we have all sorts of
little growths and differentiating
markers some of these things go away
some of these things aren't actually a
problem if we find them on imaging when
we're looking for something else we
actually have a name for them called
incidental omas and these things are not
usually meant to be found finding them
just results in more scans more
radiation more healthcare-related
anxiety more testing that you don't need
and the reality of us actually trying to
save your life by finding this thing are
almost zero
how does that feel
uh weird perfect
how about asking her if she has any
metallic objects on her oh so much can
go wrong you never had any kids right
leslie
no
you got a great oven okay
time to go got ample room in there what
is this even an image of you got a big
industrial sized oven
i'm feeling sweaty do i look sweat i
feel s you know i need to use the
bathroom one more time that's like five
times in an hour well somebody's nervous
about the ceremony or he could have a
uti causing him to have a fever which is
causing him to sweat which is causing
him to urinate quite often
oh my god ah can you stop ah are you
okay i think i'm giving birth kidney
stone yep big sucker too big sucker size
is one of the most important factors
when we're looking at kidney stones to
decide what to do moving forward you
know lithotripsy is a really unique
option where we can actually break up
the stone while it's inside of you but
we could also go in and physically
retrieve them
i want candy
what is he on morphine it's good stuff
we could also give medications like
flomax which can help in the passage of
smaller stones ron you've been sweating
in here all day oh my god why is
everyone sick yes
plenty
no you need to drink water usually i
take it neat but i will make an
exception in the name of health
last night i watched a movie with diane
and the girls
in which an orange fish is separated
from his father the children were
sniffling which i believe to be due to
the sad nature of the film
i was wrong kids are petrie dishes they
touch everything they bring it right up
to their noses mouths eat it then get
sick and then pass it along to us i'm a
grown man
i have had a cold before i need no help
so if you don't
mind
oh no he fainted make sure that he has a
pulse otherwise start chest compressions
before you begin a few ground rules i
need you to explain everything you do
before you do it so i can determine
whether i will allow you up it's funny
that's what i usually do with my
patients but the other day i had a
patient who i was um draining an abscess
off of his back which means that it was
like a pocket of pus tennis ball size
almost like what you would see on pimple
popper and as i was doing it because it
was on his back i wanted to narrate what
i was doing before i did it so he would
feel comfortable he actually got mad at
me multiple times the first time he said
please stop telling me everything you're
doing because it makes me feel worse i
apologized and then when i realized it
was taking it all along i reassured him
and said everything's going well and he
reminded me please stop telling me what
you're doing and i made the mistake and
i apologize again ah
balsa wood you could at least use
mahogany
there's something occluding your ear
it's sawdust just blue
why is him sawdust in his ear not earwax
you've got strep throat running a
prescription for penicillin why was he
admitted into the hospital a for strep
throat and b why in the world are his
eyes so right for strep throat something
doesn't add up
hey you look better i guess actual
medicine can be effective who'da thunk
please leave me alone a lot of people
don't realize this but by taking
antibiotics for strep throat you only
decrease the time that you have symptoms
by about 16 hours that whole oh i'd like
to get antibiotics so i can get better
for my trip thing doesn't quite work the
only problem i see is that your
potassium's low so just eat a banana
once in a while
ladies
ladies
see how a gag reflex what's happening
there is tomorrow at all
[Applause]
oh it's disgusting
let's go wait outside the bathroom for
tom and scare him
ready and
jerry god gross guys
oh god oh i think he might be having a
heart attack and farting simultaneously
medically speaking how would you
describe what happened to jerry he had a
mild heart attack is there a term for
having a heart attack while releasing so
much gas not really gastrointestinal
distress is common during a cardiac
event it's common during any stressful
event actually that's why the term
butterflies in my stomach exist i just
want to hear the doctors say that jerry
had a fart attack is that too much to
ask you could just have said it yourself
my man and if you're having a heart
attack the most important thing you can
do is call 9-1-1 because the time that
we have to save your heart that is not
getting enough blood flow is limited and
if you're not getting there in time we
could actually lose parts of your heart
which then can lead to rupture of valves
or walls of the heart and obviously that
could be lethal if you're having chest
pain you're dizzy it's radiating up down
left right call 9-1-1 in fact here's the
recommended guidance from the american
heart association i'm just feeling
really tired
i think maybe my allergies are acting up
i've already vomited like five times
today vomiting can be a sign of
anaphylaxis that's something we don't
talk about enough because people are
saying oh i'm vomiting that has nothing
to do with allergies it can be from a
skin allergy very unlikely just like a
mild skin allergy oh my god oh my
she's sick are you sick no yeah she's
sick
that's why i'm wearing this and misting
myself with hand sanitizer yeah that
doesn't work and it kind of reminds me
of the new dyson product that i was just
put out i have questions about that
thing i'm getting better all right
you're burning up you're burning up what
the fact that she's having multiple
systems involved watery eyes runny nose
abdominal discomfort vomiting all of
that point to the fact that it's a
multi-system issue likely to be a virus
leslie i typed your symptoms into the
thing up here and it says you could have
cancer network connectivity problems
that's actually really funny 104.1
that's how leslie you're dehydrated i'm
admitting you well
temperature is not correlated to
dehydration if she checked her skin
turgor or evaluated her lips being very
chap or checked if she was tachycardic
all those things could point to
dehydration in fact there's something we
could note on the chart dry mm which
means dry mucous membranes
it's food poisoning
i have it too i did not sleep for one
second last night did they vomit i
cracked the bottom of the toilet bowl oh
god don't say that it's important that
if you have food poisoning that you
don't take motility slowing drugs like
imodium because your body's trying to
get rid of the toxin and by slowing down
the motility of the intestines you can
actually keep that toxin in longer
creating a bigger problem warning signs
in your stool that you could have a
really bad infection blood mucus changes
in your stool caliber fever worsening
lower abdominal pain the blood is is one
of the main ones though all right uh
moving on to recycling
you okay ron
just a little tooth pain i'm fine do you
need to go to the dentist ron i don't
like dentists just a second
hey
don't extract your own tooth no
[Applause]
where's the jack
dentist pulled the tooth out yesterday
but it's always a good idea to
demonstrate to your co-workers that you
are capable of withstanding a tremendous
amount of pain why didn't you have to
have a healthy tooth extracted could it
just get a root canal
check out what happens when a doctor
lies click here to check that out crazy
patient story as always stay happy and
healthy
[Music]